hey guys and welcome to planet coaster
short introduction to this series I'm
going to be making grizzly Valley which
is going to be a Mountain Alpine themed
Park and that can be pretty tough since
there aren't actually any Alpine sets or
even a terraform tool to make mountains
within the game so far but that's
actually part of the point of this
series I basically want to not focus on
making it as look good looking Pike as I
can but really the main focus is going
to be on pushing the envelope of what's
possible in planet colu just try out
different ideas concept styles or themes
and see what you can actually do with
the sets and pieces that are in the game
currently and also really try out the
building systems and see how far you can
push those while that doesn't mean that
I'll completely disregard the park
aspects it would still be pretty nice to
end up with a nice-looking Park in the
end my main focus is really going to lie
on experimenting with the game which is
clear or fun so far and basically the
reason why I want to try this as well is
because as really great as I think the
game is looking so far many of the parks
are already starting to seem a little
very much the same and the pirate theme
is very common since it's basically the
only set along with the digit the
generic set in the game so far but I
really want to see how much you can
actually put your own touch your own
spin and style and signature onto
different parks that you make and that's
basically what I'll be trying to do here
this station over here is going to be
for a this is likely going to be pretty
weird and complicated I started off this
park with a station as opposed to trying
to start it with a entrance or a Main
Street since I really had the most clear
concept of what I wanted to do with this
station and the right that's going to
come with it is or at least in the
planning it would be a mine train but
since the game only has an arrow coaster
a red arrow coaster corkscrew that is
and a blue Benham coaster I can't really
use a mind train and decided to go with
the bnm track rather than the arrow
track since although the arrow track is
more realistically like in mind train
track I like the blue color a little bit
more and
I will make the rest of the roller
coaster quite a bit like a mine train
will be very Thunder Mountain ish with
it just going up a mountain and having
lots of scenery interaction of their
because that's something I really want
to try in this game as well especially
given how good the rock work is and how
flexible the building system is and the
theme is basically going to be a generic
Alpine like theme which is going to be
tough and gonna actually require a bit
of fantasizing about it as well since
there aren't any Alpine theme sets in
here and really just I'm trying to come
as close as I can with the different
pieces that we have so far but yeah this
is the station it's quite a standard
Alpine shape with just one main roof in
the middle and some very large side
roofs you wouldn't really call them
dormers on the front there and I will
want to actually place a facade
alongside the side as well it's also a
bit of a prototype of how they theme in
general is going to work basically there
are a couple of things you must sort of
keep in mind about this I'm using the
generic white walls to simulate the
stucco but they still have that very
little Ridge in them and a bit of a
concrete texture so it isn't perfect but
sometimes yeah I do have to compromise a
lot of things for the length of objects
also some things actually turn out to be
pretty good I'm actually really happy
about how the chimneys work as pillars
both the pillow tops and the pillar
bottoms and how you can actually use the
wooden balconies to create some wooden
fences if you sink them into wherever
you place them so we click quite happy
with how this building turned out and
also something which is pretty important
about this building is the way that the
roofs at the front which stick out like
that are really offset and this is one
of the things which I really wanted to
try because well I think a very large
potential of the game lies is actually
in the fact that you have different
grids for different buildings and
usually just completely ignore that and
just get many different grids with in
one building because being able to work
off-grid and in many different
directions makes building so much more
dynamic and it's actually a lot of fun
which are mainly be trying in this
facade which I'm placing
just outside the station but I also
tried that idea with the roofs that sort
of stick out of the station in the front
which are half a tile placed outside the
station something which I should know
it's about that is that I was I did
screw up a little bit when I placed
those and they're not entirely centered
so the station isn't exactly symmetrical
but other than that painful little
detail I'm actually quite happy about
how it turned out and I wanted to have
this facade on the side just to not make
this station look so deserted I think it
is a station which does work quite well
just as a standalone station but I
really wanted to have a small facade
next to it to make this more into a town
scene than just the station that stands
on its own and this is also where I
really wanted to try the different ideas
of combining pieces and also the
textures the main idea behind mixing the
tech students over here is to use the
castle walls as foundation walls for the
buildings use the generic white walls
for the stucco and use the wooden walls
to actually get those wooden upper
floors which is quite commonly do see in
alpine buildings and amazement a
mishmash of different wooden things to
try and get the woodwork which you also
really do often see in Alpine buildings
in which wasn't quite too easy one of
the things which is really a crucial
thing which I just cannot do in the game
so far is how Alpine buildings often
have these diagonals and slanted wooden
beams but what I am actually really
happy about is how you can use these
details with control and shifts to
really combine different pieces into new
things and that was mainly that was
actually the main thing that I was
looking forward to try in this game
since the tools are actually so flexible
and the placement in terms of how you
rotate things and how you place things
is so flexible that I think a very large
potential lies in trying to combine the
different pieces into new users so
basically trying to combine those castle
pieces and the top wall pieces to make
some battlements like on that tower over
there but also I actually found it was
really cool to do as well is to combine
the horizontal wooden beam
with the horizontal rooftops and put
some of those smaller wooden things
sticking out which you can see on that
middle building which I just made next
to that Battlement Tower where you can
create some cornices just by combining
different wooden pieces which I'm
actually really happy about as well I
just wanted to take a quick sidestep
here to make the roller coaster I
basically wanted to make it very mine
train like and this is where a pretty
big issue is going to lie in the fact
that it's a mine train with a bnm track
which makes no sense but following
nearly everything else it's going to
follow my train logic I did try to add a
looping at some point in time for Tanton
workouts now the last building over here
going to be very similar to the
buildings I already have but still
really trying a couple of new things
like having the bottom floor stick out
over the second floor actually want to
try the opposite as well in the future
with the second floor that sticks out
over the yet bottom floor that would
actually be really cool to do and
otherwise it's still pretty simple and I
do have to say this is where I do fear
the park is going to be quite repetitive
since even though with the with this
combination of pieces I am quite happy
about how Alpine like it actually turned
out but there aren't any different roof
colors or different pieces that I can
use so I'm really afraid that in the end
it is going to look very similar and
repetitive if I keep too many of these
buildings on so while there are still a
couple of ideas that I may want to try
I'm not sure how long I'll actually keep
this exact theme going and that's also
one of the reasons why even though I do
want to state then this is going to be
an Alpine theme and the other themes
which I've tried just don't work out as
well aren't as flexible as this type of
theme I really probably do want to try
some different things in the future as
well our very quick tip by the way over
here if you actually place the the half
tile or quadrat I'll round castle wall
in a building just place it and then
remove it again you actually get a
quarter tile grid much like the corner
tile grid that you have in rollercoaster
country which is crazy useful and a
clear is really cool to find that out
and other than that some of the tricks
really just use chimneys for everything
I've probably said this before but
chimneys are really one of the most
useful things in this game and you can
pretty much use them for anything you so
once especially pillows they work really
well for that stuff and another thing
which I really love doing love looking
at as well is the lighting in this game
but this is something that I should
probably talk about and I'm surprised I
haven't already I decided to record this
time-lapse in still running the game so
you have that day/night cycle and I'm
really not sure how much I actually like
it it's a bit of a double-edged sword on
one hand it's really useful to be able
to look at your buildings from with
different lighting and also put some put
the lighting in real time while you're
working on the building but looking back
at the time-lapse it is really fast and
maybe a bit distracting so I would
actually love to get some feedback from
you guys if the day/night cycle is like
too distracting or if it's actually
works out pretty well for the time lapse
because I'm sort of on both sides and
we're not sure what to really do with it
yeah the lighting is really one of my
favourite parts in the game so far it's
so beautiful and even with these small
selection of lights that we have so far
it's actually very versatile as well or
what am I saying the selection of lights
they kill it quite large too compared to
how many pieces there are at the moment
and the lighting effect is also really
beautiful and it is so much fun to place
all of the lights while you're building
stuff which is one of the reasons why I
decided to actually record this time at
one speed forwarding on the day/night
cycle just because it's so much fun and
helps out a lot on the lighting to do it
while you're actually building stuff
rather than just sort of plopping it in
there after you're done with buildings
which is pretty common to do but I think
it's a lot less fun and I really think
that one of the one of the things which
this game really excels at so far is
creating an atmosphere even especially
when you have all the guests in a shot
and a lot of activity and all the
different signs one of the things which
I really think the game has put most
attention to is making the theme park
view alive so you have all of those
different signs
the guests are really active and look
really good and the lighting is very
atmospheric and that's really where I
think this game mostly excels at as much
as I love the modular building set
building tools it just isn't going to be
much without the tools to make the
area's actually come alive and actually
look like they're a real life theme park
and that's where I think this game is
really one of the that's really one of
the best point of this game I think and
sadly also something which I won't get
into in this episode yet or even the
next episode since I really first want
to finish this general area before I can
move on to connect it to the entrance of
the park which is kind of awkward and
that means it's still dead at the moment
I pretty I should probably actually add
some guests to it and just leave the
park I'm in a path to this area just to
make that look a little bit better
anyway over here I just wanted to have
that quick flat right there aren't too
many flat rides that actually fit in a
generic theme and that's one of my
issues as much as I like some of the
flat rides
obviously you can't very first obviously
they're not very versatile since many of
them are built in a certain theme and
it's not going to be very fitting to get
that skyscraper flat ride over here in
this Alpine area so really figured that
balloon ish I'm not sure actually yeah
it's a balloon type ride I'm pretty sure
those are Spanish often in real life but
it looks like it sort of fits this area
and it really fits the Alpine theme
actually and I also really wanted to try
to make a more sneaking cue at the
moment which I do have to add as good as
you can make sneaking cues in this game
and as well as the EQ system actually
works out the one of the things which
I'm really missing so far is the ability
the ability to snake your parts in the
sense that they don't break up with
curbs in the middle because quite often
in real life queues especially on the
little buildings like that are really
just one big floor with fences put over
them rather than small parts that sort
of snake their way through an
environment and I can say the same thing
about past in general one of my biggest
gripes with the game so far is the way
that parts work
it's not just I think not too
user-friendly they can be pretty
annoying but that is really something to
also get used to but one of the main
issues I think is that parts in the game
just don't really work as they work in
real-life situations and this is
something which has also been pointed
out by King rct3 in the forums the the
fact that paths in real themeparks very
often especially around Main streets and
such are religious endless large seas of
concrete that artists like everything is
path accepts the planters and the rides
and they're much more fluid and sort of
flow everywhere in real life theme parks
whereas with the path system like this
where paths are based on a central
spline and you change their width and
length paths are more of a thing that
sort of snake their way through an
environment rather than everything is
parts and you decorate around that which
is how you would normally see it in real
life theme park so it's it's also really
way too hard to actually make a good
plaza or to make a large open area where
people can sit and relax or have some
flat rights as well so that's something
which I don't like about the game so far
but it's really one of my biggest and
only problems with the game so far
anyway about this roller coaster itself
it's going to really feature a mind
train like style forget about the idea
of adding a looping that was completely
stupid and really didn't work out in the
end it's going to be quite similar to or
at least inspired by the Expedition
Everest also a bit bit grisly runaway
mind trains in Hong Kong which is one of
my favorite rides and of course also
very Thunder Mountain ish I hope at some
point in the future to make this all
connected to the ground with rockwork
which is going to be pretty tough but
that's really the idea behind this ride
it's not going to stay like this
with being pretty huge and support
sticking out everywhere but I really
want to make it on a mountain with
perhaps even a castle on top of the
mountain I think that would be pretty
cool to try and basically have Rock work
and tunnels and scenery which the
coaster interacts with along the ride
because that's one of the things I
really want to try and see if it's
possible in the game which is going to
be pretty tough which is why I'm still
procrastinating
a Thule today but that's really what I
want to try here aside from that the
general area is going to be pretty
standard just sort of paths that flow
about everywhere and some restaurants
and other things and flat rides here and
there on the topic on the topic of which
actually I didn't actually put anything
in the building next to this station
which is purely because I forgot to put
anything there which is a very awkward
thing to say and it really is in
retrospect but yeah I forgot to put
something in there so I might want to
still change that in the future because
right now it's just a scenery and
nothing that actually functions and over
here and just wanted to have this flat
ride because it's also a more or less
generic flat ride I was hoping to
actually use the drop tower somewhere
but it's crazy huge and actually I think
way too huge for the scale of this park
so I'll probably be running out of
fitting flat rides for this area by the
time then I want to be done so that
might become a problem in the future but
I don't quite want to think about that
quite yet and at the end of the coaster
it sort of split up into two areas
mostly also because the station is quite
far away from the mountain the first
area being the area where it really goes
through the mountain and has a lot of
interaction with the scenery over there
and then the second area where I wanted
to make it more of like a theme park
scape where it really interacts with a
path and has some small bunny hills and
helixes which isn't really realistic and
this is not especially for a BLM coaster
this isn't realistic at all but I really
just wanted to try this idea and see how
it would look so really I am sort of
stepping outside the bounds of what's
realistic here but I just wanted to try
this now I want to end this video with
just a couple of cinematic shots of the
station area since it's really the only
finished area I have at the moment and
this is really how it looks it's still a
bit of a work in progress I might want
to return to it a little bit but in
general I'm actually really happy about
how it turned out one of the things
which I'm also really happy about
how well you can layer different pipes
of buildings like I really like to have
that layering going on horizontally and
vertically so for instance over here you
have that cue line going in front of the
wall and then the wall and then there's
a floor but then there are also balcony
so there are many different layers and
it's just not one vertical wall of
buildings and the same sort of goes for
a rotation for a rotation wise for these
buildings on the side where they all
have a slightly different rotation and
even though the buildings themselves
aren't too complicated just by having
that slightly different rotation and
having the towers stick out a little bit
from the building's behind it everything
looks like so much more dynamic and
alive and this part of the park isn't
even open yet for visitors and there's
nobody here yet but even with that I
think it looks pretty live and I'm quite
happy about how it looks and at
nighttime it's pretty much the same
thing there's still a couple of areas
which I might want to relights and one
of the things about the lighting though
is that it is very local lanterns don't
really lights in too large of an area
which is quite realistic and very
atmospheric but some of the built parts
of the buildings are still a bit under
lit so I might want to get back to that
not per se with lanterns because there
are already many lanterns in here and
they do have a very pirate ish style so
that's one of the things which I think
do subtract in a way from the Alpine
theme but I may want to try some more
other floodlights and things like that
just to make the buildings light up a
little bit more because some areas are
maybe a bit dark I really love the
downward lights on these stone balls
over there it's so realistic looking
I guess people have been waiting for
this in a way I really like planet
coaster so far and I'm pretty much
addicted to it and playing it all game
so that's pretty much my opinion it's
way more complicated than that but it
basically comes down to that it's a
really cool game anyway thank you guys
for watching and bye bye